there's so many new beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most hyped products from may
to test for ourselves donnie davey the
head makeup artist of euphoria just came
out with her own makeup line half magic
and i bought a bunch of products to test
out first up we have these chrome
addiction matte eye paints they have a
lot of pigment and we're really easy to
layer and blend they don't dry down too
fast and you can use them as eyeliner
which is what i did they have this
reusable wing guide which was okay i
feel like it was a little too flimsy so
i didn't get that great of a wing with
this this glitter pill was so pretty and
the applicator made it so easy to use
plus you don't have to use a glitter
base it just dries down and stays put
the light trap glow powders definitely
do give you a nice glow and you can use
them anywhere on the face like i put
this purple one on my eyes and it looked
so cool
of course i also had to get these
iridescent face gems which are
self-adhering so you don't need any glue
for the first use you will need glue if
you reuse them these are so easy to
apply and add such a cute sparkle the
last product i got was the magic brownie
lip trick kit it has a darker and
lighter lip liner so you can customize
the lipstick the lip liner is very
smooth and creamy and this lipstick is
super comfortable on the lips this brand
as a whole really inspires you to play
with your makeup which i love and i
really liked the products that i tried
i'm excited to see what they come out
with next danessa myrick's beauty just
released this skin blurring balm powder
i got the universal shade which is
translucent and i also got the shade
four so you can use this as a primer
concealer and contour a foundation or it
can be used to set your foundation i
first tried the universal one as a
primer under my go to foundation the
texture is kind of strange it blends in
easily like a bomb would but it dries
down to like a soft matte powder finish
it really does blur a lot of
imperfections my foundation went over
this so smoothly and it did make it
slightly more matte than it usually
looks but i didn't mind then i tried the
tinted shade just as a foundation it did
take me a while to blend out but once i
did i really liked the finish this is
actually more full coverage than i was
expecting i feel like it covered a lot i
did end up wearing this for the entire
day and i noticed that i was much less
oily at the end of the day than usual it
does have a bit of a learning curve but
once you figure out how to make this
work for your skin it's a really cool
product i don't know why it's taken me
this long to try the about face matte
fluid eye paints but i'm finally doing
it these are liquid eye colors that come
in full coverage mattes or sheer shades
don't be scared by that orange swatch
that one is a sheer shade the pigment in
these is incredible they're super easy
to apply and to blend out you can build
up the color if you want and it still
feels lightweight plus i'm in love with
this packaging these are amazing and i
need more colors the espresso glassy
blush is one of those ph reactive
products it goes from clear to a pink
tint on the skin i first tried it over
my foundation and it started to break
down the product i already had on it was
peeling so much so we were off to a bad
start i tried it out on my bare skin and
it worked a lot better it's cute and a
fun idea but i'm not blown away by this
i would rather just get a blush that
works on skin and over makeup this is
the bdellium large rounded double dome
blender and it looks like a little mouth
it's basically like two brushes in one
it's supposed to blend in product really
fast and give you an airbrushed finish
you can use it with any liquid cream or
powder products so i decided i would do
a full face with just this brush i was
immediately blown away by how quickly
and seamlessly this blended in the
product plus this was like the softest
brush i've ever felt you're supposed to
do these back and forth motions and i
thought it would look so streaky but it
just looked really smooth and well
blended
because of the size it is a little
difficult to use for the more precise
products like concealer but they do sell
smaller sizes of this brush i loved it
this is the say hydra beam brightening
and hydrating under eye concealer it has
a radiant finish which had me a little
worried i don't really think radiant
when i'm picking out a concealer the
coverage is light a little too light for
my taste i'm a medium to full coverage
girl when it comes to concealer but the
finish is pretty and skin like it also
looked good when i set it with powder
but i absolutely hate the applicator on
this in my opinion it's too short it is
so stiff and it doesn't do a great job
of picking up and spreading the product
around other than that this is a very
nice everyday concealer these are the
tarte maracuja juicy lip plumps and
they're supposed to give you a
tingle-free plumping they actually are
so juicy look at how shiny that is my
first reaction to these was that they
are incredibly fragile like you want to
be careful with how much pressure you're
using because it will break so i didn't
love that but these feel so good on the
lips like i could not stop rubbing them
together it's so comfortable and
hydrating the plumping was actually
tingle free for me it just felt minty
like i rubbed toothpaste on my lips the
plumping effect is subtle but i still
really liked these
[Music]
you